hey guys it's dense the founder take
care and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of Viking season to the
premiere episode it's a brother's war
very you know well titles yeah cuz we
ended last season with Rollo Ragnar's
brother basically saying okay I'm gonna
fight my brother right yeah this is this
episode to know you I was gonna curious
to hear what your thoughts were because
I know you thought season one start off
a little slow this episode this gets
right down to it yeah get this idea what
a battle right in the beginning yeah
right in the beginning in the battle and
you know floki gets hurt yelling guy
gets killed like spear like this that's
rough ah but then ultimately with rolo
it was kind of anti climatic what what
hell yeah and because I just gives back
well if he gives up a says he won't
fight his brother he won't kill as a
brother right yeah and you know cuz
we've been leading a lot of stuff in
season one towards this point so I
thought okay this is what season two is
gonna be about right but then we find
out right away that's right not gonna be
it so it seems like it's gonna be
focused more on the reconciliation and
how that's good i mean there's like a
little teaser at the end where they show
some previews for the next following
episode it seems like it's now it's
gonna be about Rollo earning back
Ragnar's trust and if Ragnar can ever
trust him again it seems like it's gonna
be the phone well I mean he still cares
about him because he bribed that one uh
you know town leader to spare his life
and it's on the sacred rock though so
you know exactly he so obviously he
doesn't want his brother to die no no
but at the same time he doesn't trust
him yeah he's gonna keep med of distance
and siggy you know who is still I'm
assuming you know into him to some well
good they're gonna have a relationship
she you know she's a little manipulative
she once her power back she enjoyed
being the Earl's wife and she wants to
be powerful again but you know and we
know the role was not as smart as Ragnar
he's not as intelligent but Ragnar let's
go back to him showed his immaturity
this week um he gets a visitor you know
from across the sea there the princess
as long as law act ofthe
and I know it's I'm sorry if our
mispronunciation then Dennis night as
you can tell are neither one of us to
Scandinavian as far as I can know anyway
so yeah I'm pronunciation might be a bit
off but she comes and visits just messes
everything up and the girth is not happy
no and then at one point Greg Gard
basically is proposing that he has two
wives with two you know yeah everybody
else is doing it according to him yeah
and I'm glad that that llegara thud
there it doesn't you know all right
acquiesced to this I I'm glad that she's
like no screw you I'm leaving in this
very good moment to I like the moment
when you're has to decide you know he's
being pressured by Ragnar's you know
group his boys to you know you just stay
with your father and you know be the man
and all that then the end he's like you
know what no I'm gonna go with my mom
cuz his dad's been kind of acting a fool
you know recognize a great tactician
he's smart he's good in battle but
sometimes acts like a kid he's a little
mature sometimes like hey we could have
this threesome you know yeah you know I
got two hot girls let's do this but well
when it comes to the war stuff yeah he
smells good at that he even negotiated a
truce petite teen horik and uh what's
Borg yeah where are y'all go how instead
they're going to go out west yeah
they're all gonna share in all the
wealth that they're gonna accumulate
after they they take down right all the
other countries and that's not gonna
work though haha but it was a good way
to stop the fighting and focus on one
thing and they can kind of just partner
up for this endeavor right but yeah on
the side of you know with his wife and
his mistress which I guess assuming that
she's gonna be his new wife because like
Eartha divorces him I hope and I don't
want to see her god I love Cole she
hasn't Winnick is yes well if you watch
the the commercial yeah a little teaser
the teaser I think it wasn't just for
the next episode but just for the season
in general you see that she is not gone
and she is going to be also like
maneuvering for power
yeah she's got her own as well and you
also see why they recast Bjorn yeah
because he's gonna show up I forgot the
actors name but he's he's basically like
a 20 something year old guy I don't know
what age they're gonna say the character
is but when I see the guy he looks like
20 something right so I don't know if
they're gonna say he's 18 or was i I
didn't see that coming i wouldn't have
thought they would have done a big time
jump this soon in this early in the
series but I mean that's cool yeah we
don't know within the season right wind
this guy's gonna show up and be that but
apparently he's gonna have an axe to
grind with his dad oh yeah i mean he's
yeah he's gonna be spending all that
time with his mom yeah he's gonna resent
his father and you know he may be coming
for his father yeah yeah he's got his
father's you know skills and hopefully
some of his wisdom and it's good so I
was in high school like I know you
thought she's in one got so so sorry I
just give you a hope for season 2
anything it's gonna be a little faster I
think so I think so it's still not quite
as let's say intricate of some is
something like a Spartacus yet yeah I
think it's you know with this episode
you know we know what's happening we're
know where it's going and so maybe as as
the episode is gone things will get a
little more complex but yeah I mean it's
still solid I still enjoy it yeah I
think it's good i think michael hurst
you know again writer from the the
tutors he says his hands all over this
and his mind so nice thing is we're
getting a clear direction the show
doesn't really try to trick you or be
too deep but it's kind of like I said it
gives you Vikings the show is Vikings it
gives you Vikings and hopefully you
enjoyed Vikings you know like I do and
you hope you like the show but yeah
that's what the show does it delivers on
what it on its title hmm alright guys so
that's what we thought of the episode
you can post your comments below on the
website pink CARICOM or on your YouTube
channel think Carol pro make sure to
subscribe to that let's come chat with
us on Twitter a lot us Dennis and I know
what you think of Vikings you know how
do you like it or is it a nice game of
thrones a filler before you know April
comes along so you can watch that we're
at think hero i'm at griffin de and we
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans and
make sure you like that page and share
video on Twitter and Facebook and
whatever thanks
you